this is just endlessly funny and I
wanted to talk about it with you at the
top of the show today so two nights ago
Donald Trump did this emergency address
about something that's simply not an
emergency undocumented immigration to
the United States and his desire for a
border wall and then after that Nancy
Pelosi and Chuck Schumer as the leaders
of the Democrats in the House and Senate
respectively gave this sort of awkward
response speech where they were both
sandwiched behind the same lectern and
it was just kind of weird but it was
still a good thing that they did it and
it was a good thing that networks
covered it because this was not a normal
presidential address it was more like a
State of the Union in that it was a
political speech and as such it made
sense the Democrats be allowed to give a
rebuttal and that networks cover it
we've now learned that the Democratic
rebuttal speech to Donald Trump's crisis
speech had more of an audience on
network and cable television then Donald
Trump's speech itself and it is so funny
because for the guy who is all about
ratings and popularity it's got to be
killing him that he gave this ridiculous
address to huge fanfare about how it's a
major crisis he's gonna do a big boy and
tell us what needs to happen and then
the Democratic rebuttal by the people
who were telling him were not giving you
the money for the wall gets more of an
audience than he the actual speech that
Trump gave and we have preliminary
numbers Trump's speech drew a twenty
eight point one household rating in
metered markets on ABC CBS FOX Fox News
NBC CNN and what which one am I missing
here MSNBC I guess the following 15
minutes during which the Pelosi Schumer
rebuttal took place got a twenty nine
point three okay so it's about four
percent bigger audience for the rebuttal
in the same markets and on the same
networks now the reality is the facts
don't care about your feelings and
normally the State of the Union address
gets a much higher rating than the
rebuttal that happens after the fact in
this case that's not the way it went and
about four percent higher ratings for
the rebuttal so it's not a huge thing
that this happened but it is notable
because number one you have someone
whose entire presidency has been
effectively predicated on how popular
are they the great ratings they got on
television as a reality show host and it
has to be absolutely killing the guy and
he actually gets fuel or momentum for
policy from how popular it appears to be
to the American public but it's it's we
don't want to for any moment mistake the
reality that audience size doesn't
determine whether there is a crisis
audience size and ratings don't tell us
who lied and who told the truth the
popularity of a speech doesn't give us
any information about what the correct
policy decision needs to be but it
matters the Trump and it matters to his
audience which is what makes it
hilarious normally it wouldn't even be
worth mentioning this but because of
Trump's temperament and his obsession
with the ratings it becomes a very
interesting side story and the one way
in which it sort of does matter more in
a real way is that more Americans chose
to watch the adult discussion about
immigration with Nancy Pelosi and Chuck
Schumer then nine minutes of Donald
Trump's unhinged lies and appeals to
emotion what that might lead to is Trump
flipping out on advisors who supposedly
pushed him to even do this because
there's an how a report in The New York
Times which claims that Donald Trump
didn't even want to do this speech on
Tuesday night and that he thinks his
trip to the border wall today I believe
it's scheduled for is a waste of time
which would be interesting because that
means that Trump is somewhat connected
to reality about his waste of time
strategy on this issue and he'll be
looking for people to blame given the
ratings loss to the rebuttal speech but
the one way in which this could still
benefit Trump is if he ends up using the
address as a pretext to more credibly
justify declaring a state of emergency
Pat and that's the question mark that
remains regardless of the ratings is
that a pretext to set up declaring a
state of emergency to commandeer money
for his wall I think he it's entirely
possible that he hasn't even found out
about the ratings report yet because you
know how
his aides give him a propaganda file
twice a day and it's filled with like
pictures of positive news and just Trump
looking good I think in the same way
maybe his aides are shielding him from
negative news and just are trying to
insulate him so he may not even know
about this yet it's possible that he
doesn't although it's gotten some
coverage even on networks that Trump
reluctantly says that he watches I think
the one miscalculation here was that
people who are already already trumpets
are totally in 100% on this dumb wall
they believe there's a crisis they want
the wall the whole thing if you're not
already in that group if you're even
moderately skeptical of the so-called
border crisis or of Donald Trump as a
truth teller
I don't know that you turn on that
speech Tuesday night and find it so
compelling that it changes your mind I
think if anything you realize
something's not sounding quite right
here but will ultimately see what the
impact is we don't know it yet that's
for sure today's program was made
possible in part by better help.com
slash Pakman better help is an online
service that gives you access to your
own experienced fully licensed therapist
via phone video and text when you see a
therapist in person in their office it
can take three weeks on average before
you're able to get in for your first
appointment but with better help you're
matched with a therapist who fits your
needs within just 24 hours and you get
the same professional service and the
best part is that better help is less
expensive than seeing a therapist in
person as well plus you will have
totally unlimited access to the
therapist you can talk to them whenever
you want on your phone or computer and
because better health believes in what
they do they also have a full money-back
guarantee if you're not happy with the
service you'll get a full refund no
questions asked all of their therapists
go through an extensive vetting process
and are required to have at least three
years of experience before joining
better help so you know you're getting
someone who's fully qualified to help
you but if you don't think that your
therapist is a good fit better help lets
you switch to someone new at anytime if
you've been thinking about getting
involved with therapy you
really check out better help just click
the link underneath this video